Welcome
back, everybody.
Today is what episode are this? Episode 102
back at pod two fifty six. It is Wednesday, January 21,
2PM central time out in Nashville.
I don't know why I'm saying that. I'm in Colorado.
It's not that time for me.
Someone's in Nashville. Someone's in Nashville, it looks like. Someone's in Nashville.
Yeah. You're stuck with me today. We've replaced Iko with a special guest Ryan,
the lead project developer for Mugena firmware. But
how are guys doing? Are you frozen?
Yes.
Yeah.
It is cold AF out there. Like all the water is ice. Like what's going on?
Did you get a lot of snow too or just ice?
It was like
ice falling from the sky. Not hail, just sort of like ice. I don't know. I don't know how to describe it. I'm not familiar with this stuff.
Yeah. I was lucky to get out of Nashville last week. I I didn't change my flight to Friday, so I left Saturday.
There were like no Ubers and then 10 Ubers and then one Uber.
And I ended up just getting like a friend of a friend to drive me.
But we were like in the ditch at one point because a tree had fallen on a power line getting through a neighborhood. Like
I'm lucky I made it to the airport.
I'm
amazed that your flight actually was happening.
For sure. So it was supposed to be Saturday morning and it didn't happen until Sunday at 8PM.
Okay. Yeah.
Sunday.
Yeah.
Yeah. So I was trapped there for quite a little bit but
was pretty At the airport this whole time?
No, just in Nashville at the park Okay. And
Yeah. So that's madness. Yeah.
But yeah, what's been going on guys? We had an awesome NEMS
and tele hash last week. That was fun times.
It was. So we've turned,
we've all decided to make a
sous vide mass manufacturing business. Is that correct?
Yes, that is correct.
We're dropping everything going all in on sous vide.
And donuts.
Donuts? And donuts. Oh, we could make donuts.
You boil them? How do you make donuts?
Fry them. We'd need to put it in
batter.
Okay. I'm on Bitcoin Park's
Twitter. I don't see a livestream,
so
hopefully, is recorded. And if I mess up the livestream, then so be it.
It looks like it's recording now.
Good. Yeah. Thank you, Iko. We're doing it live, Bill O'Reilly style right now.
We're doing it live.
But, yeah, so for anyone who who didn't catch the telehash last week,
Ryan, why don't you tell them what we showcased, what you kind of walked around with your phone camera on the livestream,
got up and close with the hardware. What was on display there?
Sure.
Well, we showcased something from all the projects,
but, I presume you're talking about the
sous vide heater
sous vide cooker
that uses Bitcoin
mining ASICs to create the heat
and co produces Bitcoin while you cook.
And each part of that miner
is a very special project
from the two fifty six Foundation that you gentlemen spearheaded parts of.
Yeah. So we put this together as a demonstration
of our entire
open
Bitcoin mining stack.
So
all the two fifty six components went into this
unit.
There's,
the Ember one hash boards. Of course, there were three of them.
And
instead of
air cooled heat sinks, they had water blocks on them designed by Ryan Ramminger
of Cryobytes.
Hat tip, and thank you again. Can't thank him enough for coming through
sort of, under a tight schedule.
And with our, you know, prototype sensibilities
at play, some awesome water blocks.
So we were able to extract heat from the
three
Ember one hash boards running simultaneously
connected to
our
Libre board prototype
as the control board.
And on that prototype was running Mugena,
which was mining with the Ember ones for, like, the very first time.
And all of this was pointed at HydroPool,
which is of course our open source pool software.
So we had the entire
two fifty six stack. Did I miss anything? The entire two fifty six stack
mining
live on stream for eight hours.
And as a byproduct or maybe as a first product,
was sous vide,
several rib eyes.
It was awesome.
It was really cool. And this was pretty amazing because it was a first of all, it was a live demo, which Yes. Are always nuts. Which worked? Which worked. Right? A live demo of, like, four projects
that had, very recently got into the working state.
And it worked. I don't know. My my mind was blown. I was I was very impressed. Obviously, there was a couple hiccups here and there, but it worked. Like, this stuff works.
I don't know if you guys felt the same, but when I was standing there or sitting there on stage
with this machine heating a stake in front of us,
my mind was just racing with all these ideas. It it really felt like,
holy smokes, everything is unlocked. We can build whatever we want. I don't know if you had a similar feeling. It was so cool.
I I did. I did. Like, there's so many amazing applications for this stuff. I I think
my mind was racing with potential applications that day, and it actually still has,
since then. You know, I busted out the space heaters for,
this inclement weather we're having, and I was like, man, could I fit some some
number ones in there? I could probably fit some number ones in there.
A 100%.
And now
that all these have been showcased running together,
what was our big takeaway? Our big takeaway, I think, was like,
we want to spur community development on each of these projects. Right? And so it's now everyone listening to the show, 10,000,000 listeners opportunity to really take a look under the hood and
get this thing running at your house, at your office, start tinkering and
start making some changes, playing around with it, make suggestions,
join the Telegram community, right? Two fifty six Foundation at two fifty six Foundation on Telegram
Because this is where the snowball effect, like, really starts.
One of the things I think is especially cool is that this stuff is open source. A lot of people
well, some people, they they create projects and they're like, we're gonna open source it, right, as soon as it's done.
We we have developed this for the most part out in the open,
and now
everything is on GitHub. Github.com/256foundation.
It's all there.
This isn't like,
you know, open source in name only, open source coming soon kind of thing. It's really there.
So you don't need to
ask for permission. You can just you can just do things like go get this, build it, hack on it.
Yeah. Is that
like a
is it just a current quirk? Because it does feel
I'm a little ignorant here. This is all new to me in the past two years, but it does feel like there's two camps of open source. It's like,
I don't really know if this works yet, but here's what I built. Please go look at it. Tell me what sucks and tell me what's awesome. Then there's the,
this is gonna be super polished and then we'll open source it.
And I don't know what ethos
is newer or is is what part of this unique to mining do you guys think? What do you guys like, do you have any context here? Is it was it different in the computer space? I'm not as well versed in it.
It I think it's it's all across the board in all the the different fields.
One thing that
is
is absolutely true is that there's there's a huge popularity, sort of a street cred associated with being open source. And so we see lots of people who want to
cash in on that,
but,
you know,
they want the open source street cred. They want the open source popularity. They want the boost in productivity and development that comes with open source, but they don't actually wanna
give up the source. Maybe they're worried about
someone else,
beating them to their own idea or something like that.
But, yeah, I've I've seen a lot of people who
seem very willing or seem very interested in jumping in on open source to take advantage of it, but not really committing to open source, opening the source.
I think that's kind of unfortunate,
but, you know, there aren't really any rules. I guess you can do what you want.
Know, I just wanna make it clear that we we've kind of we at least I reject that. Like, we are publishing the source, you know, there it's very possible there may be stuff there that doesn't work a 100% yet. We'll try to make that as clear as possible in the read me
for that particular project, you know, everything we know, things we don't know, things that, you know, need improvement.
But I'm fully convinced that's how we win. Right? It's just get it out there. You know, engineers may have to swallow a little bit of their pride. Right? It's like, this is something that I've been working very hard on and
there might be problems.
But Mhmm. I think it's worth it for the
the all the benefits that come,
to Bitcoin and Bitcoin mining from open sourcing and getting it out there.
Do you It's think
a, it can require a bit of a mindset shift.
It's kind of a challenge to your ego sometimes
to be like, well, this isn't completely a 100% polished or ready to go, but I'm gonna push it anyway.
And someone can, you know, see the history of, like, the mistakes I've made and the things I've learned as I go.
But,
you know, so I I mean,
I'm just trying I'm just
explaining things I've been through in my own head. You know? Like, this you you when you're not used to it, you get this feeling of, like, I don't know if I should show this to the world yet. It's not ready.
But
Yeah. There's, like, this relinquishing of control that you have to get over.
And
that's how it feels to me. And, you know, if you asked me six months ago, I would have been like, I wanna solve how to do this with the thermostat and the miner, and then don't tell anybody about it. And it's like, how far is that gonna get me? One.
Two,
like AI tools, people can hack, reverse engineer anything. Like how do you really,
it all boils down to like, will you use the state to enforce your patents and ideas? Yes or no? Otherwise, everything should be open source. Like it kind of relies on a state apparatus, which is interesting. That's a philosophical discussion though.
Will you use the state apparatus to sort of
enforce your copyright?
But can you even? Right? Exactly.
Yeah, it's not. Almost in all cases, requires writing fat checks to lawyers,
is
tangential from what you actually want to do. Exactly. Do you wanna spend your time, effort, and money, like,
huddling
these ideas or do you wanna actually see them work and get out there?
All the fears people have are, are just totally overblown. I mean, whether it's the fear of someone's gonna steal my idea or some company thinking,
oh, well, we can't I mean, this happens all the time in companies. Right? Like,
oh, well, if we expose our software, then people will know how our hardware is designed, and then they'll steal
like, they'll not only steal our software, but, like, they'll know our special inner workings of our special chips.
Whether it's that whether whether it's
concern about competition or concern about developer ego or we you know, reputational damage because our code isn't as clean as our customers might have expected it to be.
Like,
once you start releasing stuff, you realize,
in the competition space
idea,
well, people say this all the time, ideas are not the hard part.
It's execution.
So A, no, one's really gonna steal your idea.
B,
you're gonna be lucky if anyone even cares. Like, you know, you have the you just you all these things are sort of imaginary
and
the best you know, you can get all the benefits from just
just You just scream it from the rooftops. Like, who's actually gonna go copy you?
And and when you do kind of silo yourself with the closed source proprietary
empire vibes, especially
first mover advantage. Right? Huge market share, like the Bitmains of the world, for example. That's how you get away with really shitty service and poor execution.
Because you built all the moats and the barriers,
which is really antithetical to Bitcoin and unfortunate.
Because in an open source kind of framing,
what's
easier than paying for all the lawyers? It's like, just like offer good services and support and build cool shit.
That sounds way more fun.
Totally. It's
way more fun. And you'll get
all the benefits you're going for.
You'll get insane
loyalty from a certain group of early adopters who are so psyched to be able to play with your stuff.
You literally don't need an advertising team. Like, the the community becomes it,
which is huge.
And it it's going to be a better product. It's going to be a better product. You're you're not
really
maybe you're sacrificing some short term profits. Maybe you're sacrificing some short term profits,
but for significantly larger long term ones. I'm I'm fully convinced of this. It's going to be a better product. It has a much higher likelihood of getting out there and getting adoption.
And especially in the case of hardware. Right? Hardware will always have a cost. Someone needs to make these and put them together and sell them. So
you can do that. You can make money.
One thing that stuck with me, I was talking to Dylan and Mike about this earlier today, seeing that test bench kit that you put together showing all the pieces, the core pillars of what the two five six foundation
has accomplished with number one, Hashboard, Libre control board,
Magena firmware, and then HydroPool is there's
totally gonna be products which I think would be really cool of these reference
projects,
specifically
Ember one and Libre board being the reference part because they're actually hardware.
Talk about a cool way to learn mining. Right? It's like buy all these building blocks, put them together.
There's money to be made there. Exactly your point, Scott. Just like saying, here's the education kit I put put together for Bitcoin mining, which is gonna be so cool to see.
Yeah. I mean, I talk about this a little bit, but with the BidX. Right? The BidX is a toy.
No doubt about it. It's a tiny little miner.
But you know what it is? It's a gateway drug. Yeah. It's a gateway drug to, a, learning about mining, but perhaps more important is, b, learning how to be a miner developer.
Mhmm. Right? It's low barrier to entry. You can get in and get started like what Ryan did with adding BidX support to Mugena. Right? It's just so easy to get in to get started and get working on this and try out your ideas. Right? Because there's lots of people out there that understand hardware,
software,
firmware,
and they just need that that,
you know, easy way to get started. That you know, first one's always free. Get in. Get get started. Right? Because this stuff is really exciting. There's huge potential.
So I I hope that
with the same thing will happen with the two fifty six projects,
right, is
who who's gonna start the next,
you know,
water heater project,
because of because of these tools? We're trying to get that water heater at the heat pump summit, by the way. So Oh, yeah. I'm working with the super heat guys. Yeah. We're gonna see if we can make it work. But a 100%, I mean, did you guys have a bunch of ideas brought to you live during the telehash or at NEMs or after the fact in your messages? Or is your brain spinning in different directions than you you were a week ago, specifically
like with your projects? So Mugena and
Ember One.
Ryan, I know is getting swamped by my team with features. So I teed him up there.
Yes. I mean, I did. I did. I actually had a lot of interest from
ASIC chip manufacturers who are like, hey, We wanna build something. You know? There was there was some talk of, like,
maybe Ember one is a good reference design for new chips, right, both for the manufacturers and people who wanna build systems with these.
Because,
you know, the way the the mining ecosystem is today, maybe these manufacturers don't have that
solid
backlog of orders for their chips that they would have hoped for. So they might be looking for new avenues to sell them.
I have a question on that, Scott. So when
you chat with a
very successful capable chip manufacturer,
they're in the business right now of designing hash boards anyways.
Right? Because there aren't many out there or any really just selling chips or just making chips solely. When
they look at like an number one reference design, do you think they say,
Oh, this is amateur hour.
What can we learn from this? This could be an ignorant question. I don't mean to sound mean. Or do they say,
we can add a lot of value to this.
Is there anything they can learn from it? Or is it more so we're trying to convince them to get bought into the mission where they
improve the reference design from their experience? And then back to the snowballed comment, it just gets better and better, this reference platform. Or is it pretty simple? Maybe the third the third option is it's pretty simple that there's there's not much more complexity here. I don't know.
Well, I think it's all those things. Definitely. Okay. What I've seen is
there's a lot of excitement surrounding
Bidax and especially at Nims with what two fifty six is doing.
And I think that they're seeing that and wanna get involved.
They want they wanna get involved, which is a huge change, of course, for me. Right? I have not experienced this before.
It was mostly me sort of antagonizing
them being like, you know, can we do this? And then just ignoring me. So the tide has kind of changed
there.
That's exciting to see.
We've talked with both sort of managerial
types at these companies,
not necessarily the technical side. And the managerial types seem, you know, like they are,
they can see the value in doing this, and they wanna figure out how to do it. They have different corporate structures, and I think it requires some finesse as to how to get,
you know,
the maybe more traditional owners of the company to get involved. But,
you know, the the gears are are starting to turn, which I very much like to see.
And then on the other side,
I've had conversations, Ryan,
also with the technical side,
the more engineers at
these companies.
And it's really interesting. They're just fired up. They wanna talk about how this works. I
kinda feel like they're
obviously very good at what they do and don't have anyone to talk to about it. I don't know. It's just really cool to
geek out on this stuff and they absolutely love it and wanna learn more.
So I can see that
making
their lives easier. If they wanted to
bring up tests for new chips, if they wanna prove out different designs,
I can see that. Yeah, here's an idea.
Yeah. I mean, if I, if I were on the inside of these companies
coming out with a new chip,
I mean,
building a
one chip hash board like Bidax or a
stack of chips, but not a full hash board like Ember one, Like those are those are intermediate steps you'd probably go through within the company as you're bringing this up.
Why not
start with the BIDX,
one chip style design, and then progress to an Ember one style design
and just
make these public along the way. Like Yeah. The engineers are probably at these companies. They're like, wait a second. How come these guys get to talk about it and have fun and I have to be silent in the basement? This is bullshit.
Join us. But just imagine that you came out with it. Look how much fun we're having.
If you had a new chip,
you could simply drop it in
to, like, Ember one form factor.
Imagine how quick how quick developer
as
much else on the board. Let's say it was just an incremental incremental improvement to the chip that's already there.
Drop them in, reuse the power supply, reuse whatever, plug them in.
You could,
you know, this is not what you would do, but you could you could basically plug that straight into our whole sous vide project.
You've already got Mugena
sitting right you know, so
much of this already works, you know, just
take new chip and go.
And in in this glorious future, when they do wanna sell chips
to
the public,
which I'm convinced is going to happen eventually,
this is this is an obvious route to take. We saw this in the sort of in the microcontroller industry with Arduino.
Before Arduino,
micro microcontroller dev boards were sort of hard to come by, and they were kind of goofy. And then it just seemed like overnight, once the Arduino picked up speed, every microcontroller
manufacturer
had a, you know, sort of Arduino compatible dev board to showcase their chip. Right? That meant that someone who is thinking about who is evaluating this chip and deciding if they wanna use it can just get this dev board.
They can basically get it up to speed, test out the features that they want right away,
and then make a huge order for chips.
Yeah. And it's not to say there can't be big, massive, like, architectural level overhauls or improvements and upgrades over time with how the the hash boards are designed or laid out, but you do seem to get, like, way more bang for your buck in terms of,
okay, this is kind of the standard. This is the reference design. You can morph it in size or scale and then you can maybe
squeeze out five, six, seven generations of chips on top of it before we really shake things up. It almost reminds me of like when they change the socket type on a motherboard, but you get a couple generations in between. It's kind of like that.
Yeah. That's how it tended to work in
phone chips at least a couple years ago when I was involved.
Know, you, you do, first of all, these reference designs for like a phone,
the size we're all used to, they start out as like
18 by 18 inch circuit boards, kind of like the way
our SUV heater is a big, a big, you know, one foot by two foot rack of stuff so that it's all exposed so that you can get all at it so you can probe anything you want. It's not you don't miniaturize it till you're done
because it's hard to work on something that's miniature.
But, you know, but they they do it. You know, you would design a phone chip, and then you'd get a couple generations out of it. And they were they were sort of incremental improvements on each other, not complete massive
total redesigns.
Yeah. What comes to mind of
different methodologies is like, and we don't know much about it. Maybe you guys do more than me. It's like Oradyne seems to be doing something very different with their hash boards than
what Bitmain is. And would that be possible to throw their chips on
more or less the same Ember one? Scott, could you speak to that at all?
Absolutely.
Absolutely. There's not that much difference in the hash boards. Right? All these chips are are very similar in the way they connect. Right? They're they're big, long chains powered in series. They cascade the data through them all. The industry seems to have settled on on that as a strategy, right, as opposed to like a big monolithic chip or something like that.
So they're very similar.
They all have their their own tweaks and their different ways of doing it, guess, sort of their market differentiator,
their secret sauce.
A low level it's very similar and I guarantee you all of them have made single chip boards to test out the chips guaranteed I've seen a couple of them
it's you just absolutely have to do it especially early on. Right? When you're Right. Doing a shuttle run of your ASIC, you've spent,
you know, just a couple million dollars to get to this point, and you wanna see,
how it works. Right? Because you you need to show off how it works to raise the
the subsequent
tens of millions of dollars to move forward.
Switching to Mugena,
because it's software exclusively,
there's almost like nothing lost between an architectural level change really.
In my mind, it seems like it would compound even more and it's
additive.
It's continuously getting better and there's more features. There's more support for more machines, more hash boards, more chips. Is that is that how you're thinking about it, Ryan?
Yeah.
Absolutely.
I mean, we've we've tried to build it so that the parts that
should be independent of each other,
like the part of Mugena that talks to the pool,
that has absolutely zero idea and depends in no way
on what ASIC chips you're using,
how you communicate with the ASIC chips,
how many ASIC chips you have. Like, these things are completely independent. So everything that should be
modular and independent is.
So that means whatever whatever piece you're going in there to
improve or do a new generation of, you can you can focus on just that piece
and you can trust that all the pieces around it
already work
and are already proven.
You know, if I'm running a chip driver,
well, I know that I've been running the same
stratum v one client.
You know, it's been successfully mining for
six months. Like I don't, I don't doubt it. I don't, know, when something isn't working, I know exactly where to go look, the part I just changed,
you know?
So,
so that applies to hardware changes that would apply, you know, not, and, and conversely,
you know, there's a,
someone has already sort of vibe coded a stratum v2 client from Regina, and that's available on a branch.
But, you know, if someone goes in there to work on stratum v two or maybe an entirely new way of communicating with pools, or, or I've even thought,
why can't we have like
a simple mini client that just connects straight to Bitcoin D,
you know, and doesn't really go through, like a pool layer.
Like, if you're working on that part of Magina,
you know, that you can trust, oh, you know, the CPU mining part, that just works. That's been working.
I could plug in a Bitaxe. I can plug in a number one, whatever. Like, I know that I'm just working on the
the,
the job source is what I call, what we call it in Mugena. Like so
yeah.
So that's an interesting part. That happens within Mugena the same way it can happen at a system level. Know, this is a new hash board, but I trust the rest of the system. It happens inside Mugena too. Like this is a new little component. I trust everything around it. I don't have to redevelop everything around it.
Well, in the new communication protocol too, like you just made me think that if the whole stack up's open source,
it allows mining developers
to say, why don't I think about this at first principles? Why are we doing it this way? Everything
right now has been built off CGminer.
What does that stand for? Computer graphics? These
things have nothing to do with computer GPU. GPU. Okay.
Which they're not. They're not either of those things. So
not to say that we have to overhaul everything, but it allows you to, I think, think more freely about
what you can build and what
our end goal is and what we're trying to do and ways to get there.
It lowers the cost,
the, the complexity, the effort required to experiment with any one of these pieces.
You can, you can get a lot more experiments for your book. If you, if you could, especially now with AI.
Yeah. If you could just low risk, try something, low risk vibe something, like you could take 10 wax at the pinata instead of one
long,
carefully planned,
risky
change. You know, you try try a different protocol every day. You know? Like, it's if if it's easy, then you can iterate faster.
I know that
a 100% of ASICs
mining ASICs up to this point have been prototyped with CGMiner.
Absolutely. There's no way that someone bringing up a new chip wants to write a new stratum client, so they just grab CGMiner.
Some of them have gone to production with it.
All the big ones have gone to production with it, which is unfortunate because they are not respecting the GPL license that c g nine is under.
But I would say that
doing that process with Mugena
is gonna get you a lot further, a lot faster.
And,
you know, what I'd like to see is
you can you could go to production with it. Like, you can develop
your,
your production
mining firmware on top of it. Mhmm.
What ideas for firmware are top of mind after this past week, Ryan? Any new ones?
Or is it more so popular ones that you think should should get attention next?
Well,
to be honest, I mean, there's, there's already,
you know, solid,
long roadmap of productization,
you know,
polish
that needs to be done
to make existing things work or things that people would expect are just table stakes.
You know, like
Dylan, I'm sure would chime in here like, hey, the API barely does anything. We need to fix that.
You know, there's lots of things.
So, so, know, these, there's a lot of things that aren't revolutionary
features
that we've gotta work on for a while.
You know, even the Ember one demo
at the tele hash, like we those Ember ones weren't hashing at their nominal hash rate yet. We haven't
we've barely spent any any time,
optimizing some of this stuff.
The pool
the pool client doesn't in fact handle multiple pools right now.
We wanna be able to work on setting power targets
through the API.
There's just a ton of stuff like that. That's not necessarily revolutionary,
but, you know, Regina started from, started natural progression from scratch.
I would say we kind of had our zero, we we're kind of at our zero to one point
And now,
you know, it's got some work left to make it up. Yeah, literally all these All pieces
these pieces came together for the first time. What was it? Like twelve, thirteen hours before the Telehash started. So
first
LibreBoard boot up as well from Schnitzel. And it worked. We were hashing to HYDRApool,
which is so incredible. Speaking
of HYDRApool,
d plus plus huge shout out for the telehash and the
HashDash dashboard that she made at -.256f.org.
She's been continuing to work on it. I don't know if you guys have been keeping up with her messages, but it's awesome. So cool. This is gonna just,
I don't know, this is exactly what we want to see, but this just launched
an amazing,
in my opinion, revolutionary
new dashboard for pools. It's really cool. It's really, really cool. She has gamified it for sure
with avatars
and your MPUBs. And I even think you can link to companies. Like you can use your URL for your website as your username.
Twitter.
Yeah, Twitter. It's so cool.
It's so cool. Like
mining
to a pool, especially when
using these little hash rate monitors, it doesn't have to be so boring, right? We can add this social aspect to it. I think it's a fantastic idea. Oh, for sure. I can't wait to get all the hash words migrated over from there. I think there's still a few on
the existing pools that two fifty six Foundation has set up.
Oh, one other thing I wanna talk about too is like this, this was reiterated at NEMs, but it was topic of conversation today in some chats we had is like
a lot of these other mining projects that people are building and working on to solve pain points, be it managing giant fleets or
on my end controlling for home heating or whatever it is, it's abstracted a layer above these core pillars
of the hash board, the control board and the firmware
and even the pool.
And so we were just talking about how much easier all that work gets once you put faith in and have an open source,
you know, kernel level Linux kernel analogy,
as Ryan puts it, of the mining stack up. If you guys wanna talk on that a little bit, I think it's super important to realize, like, why would you go spend all this time building this elaborate,
super
optimized
site fleet management system
only for it to talk down to your limitations at the closed source firmware on these machines.
Yeah.
It's for the people making minor management software,
it's gotta suck.
Right? Those APIs are poorly documented,
and I I I imagine there's a number of features that are, to be desired.
So,
I hope we can create this future when you don't have to
fight against that to get, you know, to get done whatever it is that you wanna get done as far as managing fleets
of Yeah. NEMs.
Was having some great conversations with Brett Rowan
Yeah. With PyAsic.
And we were,
you know, he was just, and I just asked him like, well, what's your dream
setup for this? Like if we could change anything, because we can,
like how, how do you ideally want this to work for like a minor that wanted
that you wanted first class support
to be able to integrate into the stuff you're doing?
And, you know, we came up with all sorts of new ideas that I don't think have been done yet,
but are are gonna be pretty easy to do with Magena because we control the whole thing.
And that's where we don't really have much insight as to what that current working relationship is like with these large sites or
monitoring softwares. You know, if you have a big enough
bag and you buy a big enough order quantity of machines, maybe it is a pretty,
you know, healthy back and forth between they get what they want,
but everyone else doesn't benefit in that sense. Then
you still pose the risk of like just that bridge being burned one day, And then you're stuck, you're SOL, or that manufacturer
deciding we're not going to make air cooled machines for the next generation. And so you either upgrade your whole site to hydro or you switch to another manufacturer. Oh, and then your management
software doesn't work with that firmware. It's like, Okay, why did we get ourselves in this position?
I've heard of
large mining companies jumping ship on Bitmain because they can't get what they want out of them.
But the unfortunate part is, where do you jump ship to?
Your only other option really is MicroBT
that is famously started by a Bitmin engineer. And I think it's it's essentially just more of the same. So you're
you're making a, a sideways move.
I hope we will provide
them much, much better options.
Yeah. I don't just talking to people. I don't think many people get what they want.
I don't know how big you have to be to get what you want, but I've never, I probably never ran into someone who was big enough
to get what they wanted. And, and the cool thing is,
you know, you just, you just prick the bubble,
talking to people about stuff and the ideas just overflow. Like there is pent up
demand.
They know the problems that they have.
They know what, hey, if I just had this, it would solve so much for me. Like
there's a big greenfield here for us to go get.
And that's why I'm hopeful this,
not really launch. I mean, the repos have been public for quite a little bit of time, but, like, this live demo really gets people
excited
and coming to the realization that, like, oh, shit. We should probably look more into this and support this and fund this. Because
if that's the case where you give a little prick and everybody has ideas and everyone has the same pain points and everyone's frustrated like, Hello,
two fifty six Foundation here.
We'll do it.
So I want to make sure we do a good job getting that message across,
specifically in the sense that it helps minors of all scales.
It does. It does. I was doing a little research for my
talk on, I think it's gonna be on Friday? No. Yeah. Saturday at Plan B in El Salvador. Was doing a little research, and I was looking up the biggest miner is, Iron,
formerly Iris Energy. They're a $17,000,000,000
company. They spend somewhere in the neighborhood of $20,000,000
a month on electricity.
Holy smokes. $20,000,000
a month on electricity. That's like net. Obviously, they get credits for,
demand response and stuff like that. But these guys aren't messing around. Right? They're spending serious money. And to think that that is all on firmware that they can't control is insane to me. Insane to me. They're the whims of what Bitmain wants to do. They they use majority Bitmain machines.
Like, all that money, all that risk on this firmware that you can't control, that you don't have insight into its operation,
to me, is madness.
Once once we have a viable option, they will jump ship so fast is gonna be scary. Yeah.
Yeah.
Just imagine. I mean, there's no one they employ in their company
that's, like, dedicated to their firmware, like, because they can't.
It's actually really,
like, funny to think about. You could have a Goliath of a company like that. And when you really get down to it, it's like, yeah, no one knows how this works.
Like
Like, we have some ideas. We you know, we've we've banged on these enough. We've had enough broken ones that we've we've tried to fix that they've no doubt developed this bag of tricks for how to make it work. But, like,
how risky is that? Right? That you just have this random
bag of tricks that's,
you know, you're kind of you're just hacking it.
And, like, to have that much money on the line and be hacking it,
whew.
Let's play devil's advocate. Is it purely just the
first mover advantage?
I don't need to innovate or tell you how I do things from a lot of these ASIC manufacturers.
They're incentivized to not
well, there are some instances with Bitmain, right? Amply, need an ASIC boost, but it's like they're incentivized enough to not ruin the whole thing to lose their market share, but not enough to be transparent.
Like, just I I struggle to game theory, like, why
this is the status quo.
I think just because the
well, Bitmain is the biggest, but, you know, the three largest ASIC manufacturers,
Bitmain, MicroBT,
and Canin,
they're just they're all copies of each other. No one's doing anything different. There's no alternatives.
Right? If you wanna be in Bitcoin mining, you've got to use one of these things. And,
you know, even even the underdogs, right, with less than 1% of the market share aren't really even changing anything up yet. So
the, the I get this users, the customers are trapped. Mhmm. I get this question a lot.
Yeah. I get this question a lot. And I think, and I don't know anything more than anybody here for sure. But
my answer is always like, well, you know,
I, I don't, you don't think you have to assume evil intent.
It's more just, they just don't care.
They haven't had to care. There's nobody pushing them to care. There's no competition that makes them
change.
Like
they sell a thing. People buy a thing in volumes for a lot of money.
And so why change,
why change that until you have to, you know, I don't know. It might just be as simple as that. I mean, we're gonna, we're gonna make it so it has to change. Right? Once, once the there's a viable alternative,
the customers, think, will be the first ones to see it and they will demand.
They'll demand
essentially open source. They'll demand more control over what's going on.
I think they already want it. They desperately want it. I know
many of the large mining companies have,
you know, projects, internal projects to reverse engineer the firmware and make their own. But
yeah it's it's gonna be obvious like the decision to not run Microsoft web server and run you know Apache or NGINX right it's just it's a no brainer once you see
the benefits.
There was someone I met at NEMS. You
introduced me, Scott Chico, and he works at,
I forget the name of the company. Chain Reaction. Chain Reaction. So they've
designed their own ASIC and it got me thinking about
boutique ASIC manufacturers.
How common is that? Or is that, I mean, uncommon?
It's
there's a handful of them.
There's a handful of them. There there's a few that are, like, still in stealth as far as I know too, which is really weird because the big upstart cost to do it. Mhmm.
You know, they must see the the potential
revenue there, the numbers. And, you know, if you've got
a team that has familiarity with manufacturing at TSMC,
you're like, oh, we can do this. Mhmm.
And I
was pleasantly surprised to hear that a lot of these
either in stealth or underdog,
smaller ASIC manufacturers,
like,
they get it in the sense that at least a handful I've chat with Proto included, which is not really smaller boutique, but,
like, they're all for the
underdog alternative use case play. Right? Like, let's not just cookie cutter do what Bitmain did.
How can we do it differently? We saw that with Rig,
you know, focusing on on easy upgrades. Right? And modularity in that sense and infrastructure of the of the hardware. I'm really curious to see what comes from
these other ASIC manufacturers.
Maybe one will come about that just says, wait a second.
The two fifty six Foundation, these other
system builders are are prevalent enough that, like, we were going to make a miner, but why? I don't need to do that. Someone else can handle it. Sounds hard.
Yeah. Intel came to that same conclusion about making PCs. They
tried several times to make a PC. And a miner.
Yeah, and a miner. That's a good point. But
as far as on the CPU side of things, they realized, like, hey. We can make some really good CPUs.
We can sell them to systems builders, and they can make way more,
you know,
products and capture way more of the market than we ever could. And of course, we're going to sell them all chips. So it's
You actually get larger market share because there's no feasible way
to think of every idea where you could put an ASIC chip. Yeah. Think of or even execute on. Or execute. Yeah.
Yeah. Absolutely.
Absolutely. Let us sell you more chips.
I say this over and over again. They're like, ASIC chip manufacturers,
let us sell you more chips. We will create
customers for you.
And it's gotta be, like, 90
of the cost of a miner.
I wonder what the breakdown is. I don't maybe that's a bit hyperbolic, but it's like, okay. What's the power supply worth? Who cares? Right? You know, that's not their their big margin item. I imagine it's it's the chip. That's their special sauce. Yes, it is. It is. It's it's the the biggest ticket item on the bomb for the minor.
It's what everyone cares about. It's what they have the most R and D invested in.
I think,
well, they certainly aren't spending much on firmware development because Bitmain firmware sucks. I don't know. Micro micro p t doesn't seem that much better. So not spending much money there.
And then the rest of it, you know, they've gotta have it. So some effort goes into it, but it's it pales in comparison to the actual ASIC.
I had a funny realization this week because
I realized I've
never actually used Bitmain stock firmware. So we're flashing it onto
an old S9 and we've got an S21 and a 19 downstairs as well. Because I was just curious. I wanna see how bad it is, you know? But for a lot of us,
large miners, right? Whether you're running a couple in your house or even if you have a few hosted, right?
Or have your own little shed.
Most people are running these aftermarket firmwares, which include a dev fee, so there's some loss of profit there, but
there's already a driver for additional features in the firmware set
to the point where
I don't know anyone that runs stock firmware.
Literally, don't know anyone.
So they ship them with it, but.
Hey, Scott. What's the what's the answer? I I had, an industry person say say to me,
well, we don't want the
effort of selling chips
in a catalog market. Like, we don't really care about selling 10,000 chips to hobbyists.
That's
fair. That's fair. No, no,
you know, chip manufacturer
or very few chip manufacturers want to deal with the hassle of selling retail.
That's why they don't. That's why DigiKey exists. Right? DigiKey is a,
a retail
distributor.
Right? They take they have an account with the manufacturer.
They buy them in bulk, and they they deal with all the rest. Right? Sending one to me and dealing with, you know, my me being like,
it hasn't arrived yet. What's going on? All that stuff. So
there there's solutions here. Right? If you don't wanna deal with DigiKey,
there's other solutions. You know, we can
there's you know, from the from the bid act side of things, there's plenty of sellers that are,
quite good at doing retail sales.
The manufacturers
would be happy to buy chips in bulk.
We can get this sorted out. If that is your hang up that you don't wanna do retail sales,
let's talk. We can absolutely get this sorted out.
And even if the
order quantities, like, aren't large enough to sway them in that sense, With the building blocks of the two fifty six Foundation, all this being open source, it becomes much easier for a mega miner, a Mera,
a Tether, someone to just say, screw it. Like, we'll invest in the rest of the shoebox.
Give me 10,000,000 chips. You know?
Yeah.
Yeah. I think the, I don't wanna sell the hobbyist question sort of
betrays
a lack of imagination.
It's like,
yeah. What starts as 10,000 hobbyists
turns into
real products,
you know?
Yes.
If it's only ever going to be 10,000 chips
to people building bid access, like that's not really a great market,
but I think they're missing there's there's huge untapped markets here
that you, you just gotta get the stuff out there and see what happens. This is part of that. You can get this into people's hands.
Let them imagine products that you
that don't even exist yet. You know, all the hash rate heat world,
or anything else. And then you'll get the 100,000 chip
companies,
but they're, they're not just going to pop out of nowhere
they don't have chips to work with and experiment and ways to iterate to bigger designs.
Yeah. It's felt like chicken and egg for a long time. Yeah.
It really has. I think that two fifty six
Foundation is well
aligned to
to help break out of that, you know, chicken and egg cycle, right, of of getting these projects
kick started,
getting them the exposure that they need,
and providing tools so people can build businesses on the top of this and
place fat orders.
What else is on your guys' mind following last week?
Oh, man. I there was there was so much excitement. There was so much excitement. I I was very
excited to see,
you know, some of the other other
representatives from big mining companies that were at NEMS, like,
talking about what we're doing.
Like, we're on the map. Mhmm. Maybe
small corner of the map right now, but
this this growth is happening. This interest is happening.
It's it's not just a
weird little project anymore.
I'm excited to get I'm just kinda getting back in the saddle today after
trying to escape this winter weather that we had come through right after NEMs.
And, you know, frankly, we were we were spending a lot of time getting that demo up and running in time for the
the deadlines. But
and there's lots of
comments that have been happening in the Mugena repo,
a few PRs,
people with questions on Telegram.
I'm excited to get in the saddle here and start engaging the community better,
with a little bit of our deadline pressure off
to enable people to start contributing the things they're excited about.
Yeah. Unfortunately, we didn't mind a block,
but
telehash number four is scheduled for Thames in May.
I think so. This telehash,
you know, it was disappointing that we didn't solve a block. But I But the energy was crazy. I think the energy was crazy. I think for that reason, it was the most successful one yet. Like,
absolute it was so cool seeing the demos and seeing all the people genuinely interested in this, asking questions, talking about it.
I think it was a glorious success,
nonetheless. And that's not just like some cope. Like, it really was cool. The energy in there was fantastic,
and it hasn't stopped.
Well, some of the biggest supporters, special shout out again, were
all the HashRental
sites. Yes. Should talk about that. That was totally
surprising. I was caught off I didn't even
know one of them I was unaware of. Dylan's actually a big supporter of them. So shout out to wrigley.io.
They also supported some of their own hash rate to the tele hash during the live stream,
as well as nice hash and
brains.
What is brains? Hash Power? Yeah.
So those are three great options where you can go and
literally just
rent Hash Rate for a fixed time period. At one point we had
like an exahash from NiceHash for an hour or two,
pet a hash from the others, a couple pet I mean, it was awesome. I maxed out I think we maxed out all the miners that Wrigley had. Like, people were getting delayed saying your hash rate will come online later. Your contract will start later because we bought them all up.
I feel like that was really cool exposure for those companies, at least to me. I don't know. I was,
I guess, maybe somewhat aware of them, but to see them coming in
swinging
for the telehash was really, really cool. And I hope provided some good exposure for them.
Yeah. And it was prevalent to one of the things we talked about with Schnitzel on stage, is like these companies ability to command a pool switch across such a huge fleet so quickly, proxying everything
was another idea we were talking about with
LibreBoard and then kind of a little side development project that Schnitzel had to work on throughout
working on his grant was HashScope
kind of as a way to watch traffic through communication between
the control board and the actual HydroPool instance itself. So this is the kind of stuff that you discover is worth building or necessary to build.
And also, like, how did this not exist in the first place? No one's been verifying their shares for all these years, like, these kind of instances.
I thought that was really funny.
Yeah. And he published HashScope
open source as well. Right? He did.
You know? All the all the all the neat tools that have come out of this,
which is just the beginning. But, you know, these are the kinds of things that it takes if you really
want to to do this. If you really wanna deploy. Right? You need to do all these things. And so
it's awesome that we can
can publish those open source so everyone can benefit from it.
So new year, NEMs is over.
We're,
we're working on getting
new grant cycles issued to continue development and polishing, I think as you put it well, Ryan, of these core pillar projects, right?
And leaning into
community development, right? If you can't contribute or make a donation yourself to the two fifty six Foundation monetarily,
more than welcome to just hang out in the telegram chat, be a lurker or submit a poll request,
try to do this yourself,
see what ideas come to your mind. That's how we're really going to accelerate
dismantling the proprietary mining empire, which is awesome.
It is. We
so we got this far
with, like, $400,000.
Like Yeah. That that's chump change. So
it's just exciting to see how much that we can get done. And I'd really like to see
companies
in the Bitcoin mining industry,
realize how effective this is and and really, you know, make a tax deductible donation to the two fifty six Foundation. We will put it to extremely good work that is gonna benefit you directly,
in this in this crazy world.
The ROI is so high because you make one contribution and others do the same. And effectively,
you got a bunch of employees that you didn't have to pay for and a
huge developer and support community
the platform
is the outcome.
Crazy Yeah,
to think that that Telehash was one year
from hitting the block last year,
which feels like yesterday.
But,
just in one year, and then we're sitting there with a live demo of all the things we promised. I mean,
I don't Yeah. It's crazy. It feels not to toot our own horn, but like,
that's legit.
That I mean, to to to really get something done that works in the world.
And this was not a pure software project either. This is a hardware project.
Toot.
Hardware and software, lots of integration between all the pieces like,
and we got it done. That's that's, that's impressed. I mean, I was impressed with us.
Was very impressed. I didn't build anything. I think it's awesome. What what does Marty say? Shout out to us.
No.
Seriously,
Massive credit.
When was the last time, you know, people were,
not for novelty, but, like, mining on an open source stack?
This has gotta be
not the chip. Okay. That's fine. But
when was the last time someone was feasibly mining on like a Raspberry Pi? Well, that's not even open. Is there an instance of that? Bit x.
Okay. But I mean, prior to prior to these recent,
this recent, like, you know, the rebel strike back.
I think,
you know, it was before the advent of ASICs.
Yeah. Which was over ten years ago.
Crazy. It is crazy. It is crazy. I'm gonna talk about this a bunch in my my talk, but,
you know, Satoshi famously released
mining as a part of the first, you know, Bitcoin client. It was in there. And so that was just how mining was done, and there were several improvements. You know, we saw improvements on the efficiency of mining with CPUs,
several different, iterations of that. Then it went to GPUs, and then it went to FPGAs,
and that stuff was wildly open source. So I would say
that was the last time, you know, the fully open source stack
was used to to mine in mass.
And ten years sounds like a long time, but I think it will ultimately be viewed as a small blip in the history of Bitcoin mining, which was like this crazy,
you know, race to
become the biggest fish
and people weren't paying attention to the Bitcoin roots and ethos and open source nature and it led to all this fuckery and now we're back. Now we're back. Yeah. Yeah. I think you're exactly right. It's a blip.
Why don't we shout out some hashers, yeah? Yeah.
So I'm on dash.256f.org.
There's four forty one terahash on here. Woah.
All right. Still, let's keep going. People forgot to either change their pool or they're very kind.
Schnittel's Hashtubs online, so he might not be working right now.
Yeah. What's that about? $4.58
terahash,
which that's got to be two minors.
Yeah.
And then RevHoddle's
got a clothes dryer.
Agent P's got an s 19 x p heater. Oh, that's cool.
That is cool. Sovereign Hybrid Compute.
Their username is their company website. That's really cool. The logo shows up from their favicon and everything.
Sweet.
From Exergy, Mike's got his radon mitigation miner
and
a couple other little little solo miners.
77 on Noster has a Nerdaxe hydro, a Bidaxe broke, Bidaxe overclock, Bidaxe hydro,
BMM 101, gamma ten ninety one.
That guy's got some rad stuff.
That's pretty cool. I love that you could, like, build some custom thing
and have it have it there.
And then like this, the dashboard could be a link to your project.
Totally. You know? With pictures and all. Yeah. Love to see pictures of all these workers.
Oh, yeah. That's That's great idea. Right? If there's some way to attach like a,
I don't know, like an article or a press release or whatever it is that you want to, publicize.
Actually Well, your username can be a link. Like it could just go to a Noster post or X post or something. Man, we we could have this this could be like the the hacker news, right, of mining rights where you
Yeah. You you can hype your new project,
and get it on this sort of news feed by pointing us hash rate like that idea. It's it's it's ranked by hash rate. So
the more you got, the higher you rank. And then we could also, you know,
store a log of highest difficulties of all the machines. Like, there's a lot of cool ways to rank it. Pisande's
on here with his non mining three d printers are wasteful. It's true. Fact. And proof of print bit acts.
I'm excited to see that three d printer
next month at the Heatpunk Summit. So that'll be Is it gonna be there? Yeah. Yes. Oh, I'm excited.
Scott, you're on here with the block hitter, and you guys, we just
we're saving it for Tim's.
Good to know those machines are still running.
Yes.
Just a regular worker address,
hardestblocks.org,
bitcoingunshop.com.
Follow on x for updates.
Glitch pixels,
x x zero six nine, block or bust. Dude, this is there's so many.
Montani's on here still. Shout out to Montani. Business cat, rock paper bitcoin.fm,
Central Pennsylvania Bitcoiners meetup,
d plus plus,
Woodminer
Woodminer. D plus plus. Oh, yeah. Shout out to Woodminer.
We saw him this past week.
Eco.
And Dee's got yeah. She's testing hard. She's got a Nosta profile linked, a website linked, and her Twitter linked from her different bid access.
So
there might still be some hashers on the other pool accounts. Right? Let me pull those up. I was just gonna if we made this clear, but so if you go to -.2fifth256f.org,
you can point your mind there's instructions for pointing your miner to that pool. But in the worker name, you can put a link to a website. You can put an Oster profile. You can put a,
Twitter username,
and it all gets linked and shown on the dashboard.
Yeah. We we should probably get a,
like, little read me or something with kinda edge cases and examples of what you dos and don'ts and what works and what doesn't. I think that's a good idea. Which would be cool.
I there are still a few on
the other pools.
So Schnitzel Fish Tank Axe is on LingCoin and Backwater Mining Collective.
Shout out to those guys.
Move your hash rate to 256f.org.
These are much shorter lists, so our message has been received.
On
Whoops. I muted my mic. On Solo CK, we have boring worker name,
Ocean Pool is centralized in custodial,
Bitaxe three
and just a a Bitcoin username.
And then on Public Pool
oh, all alone on Public Pool is Stalin's Bitaxe.
You're left alone out there.
And
quite a few on ocean here.
Bible huddle.
The Exergy heating systems, def Dylan set that up today with our datum split. We we set a configuration for that. So 5% of all the Exergy heating systems at our office are are mining to the two five six foundation to Ocean. We're gonna have to do something to
with HydroPool
to split
to not use Datum and split some of our hash rate to the two five six foundation because I wanna do that,
which would be cool.
There you go. Then we could and that would be awesome because then we could advertise folks that don't necessarily have lotto miners, but they want to, you know, earn some Bitcoin but still donate to the two five six foundation to just split the hash rate
without needing datum. That would be sweet.
That would be sweet. Yeah. You figure out how to do that, you know, if your miner firmware doesn't support it yet.
Mhmm. We talked about maybe some kind of proxy mode for HYDRA pool. That's Mhmm.
Rekkles Systems,
guys are fun projects at Toshis Starter. Shout out to Rekkles. Apotheosis,
it was good to see you last week.
Zurka Sehash and Bitaxe wannabe just an s 17 pro.
This might this list might get really long if we make it too fun.
Sounds like a good problem to have. It does. It does. Well, then we'll make it a real competition. You gotta be in, the top 10 or something. Top 20.
Well,
sweet gents. What else should we hit on before we wrap here?
Heat Punk's coming up. Heat Punk Summit is coming up. Excited.
One month, it'll be happening in one month from today.
We're gonna have a lot of awesome demos. I'm really excited to say that
Kanan is being really cool. They're gonna
have a workshop session where the whole premise is
tell us what you want in Home Mining products.
And it's gonna be an awesome opportunity that
I think is sometimes hard to convey at a lot of the larger conferences, right? You just show up to their booth and you're like, I think you should do this, right? But this is an
intimate setting
where the whole purpose is, you know, let's brainstorm this, let's whiteboard it, we're gonna have a TV, we're gonna take some notes,
we'll have some hardware on the table,
do's and don'ts, what you like, what you don't like and it'll be really fun. That's a great idea.
And similar
with you guys, I'd love to do a little workshop with the two fifty six guys here on-site
to really get people
excited about building on top of adding, developing to the the two fifty six Foundation
core projects
and get the ideas flowing of of what's unlocked for them across scales. You know, we'll have guys from Andy with the the proof of print,
Bitcoin miner,
all the way up to large scale district heating, you know, and Mara and those guys. So it'll be fun.
Yeah, let's do it. I'd be happy to talk about this stuff all day. So Sweet.
Yeah, this is gonna be great.
Well, stay warm you guys. It's
50 and sunny here in Colorado, so I might go on a walk with my sweatshirt off. Sorry.
I think
at this point, I I think we need some snow out there. Right?
Yeah. That's true. I haven't been up to the mountains in a minute, but we do need that for our little ski adventure. Yeah. We're to push some of this nonsense that way. We're supposed to get another snowstorm like this weekend.
Fingers crossed.
It is not safe to go for a walk in Nashville.
Yeah. You'll slip and fall. Some of those pictures Or a tree will fall on
your head.
Like, it's bad.
Well, Godspeed.
Yeah.
Until next week, and we'll have Eco back, and I'm sure we'll dive deep into what's next in more detail for a lot of these projects.
And we should get some some guests on soon. I wanna start doing that more in the new year, guys, because,
like, Heatbit came out with another miner yesterday that's got even more Hash Raid and
that water heater that we wanna learn so much more about. Like, this is the opportunity, I think, to to really showcase
what people are building outside of the standard form factors and
and how
the open source projects can accelerate it.
Shout out to Heatbit. They're a supporter of Yeah. Two fifty six Foundation.
And
I think that they have,
got some value out of out of what we're doing, which is exciting to see. You know, gotta be exciting if you're a manufacturer and you want to build a space heater. Right? Like,
you know, as I've said before, you you can't go to market with a product that is just
old,
Antminer hash boards in it.
I think that's how Heap It started, but that doesn't scale, and they obviously realize that too. And so I think this new one is their own custom build.
And,
yeah, that's that's what we need to see. That's what people need to be doing.
Yeah. It is awesome. They said they were gonna open source some stuff too, didn't they? Yeah. I believe they are. I believe they are. Their software, which is really cool.
You know, and I'll just finish with that note.
It's not just let's do open source because it makes building faster. That's true. I mean, there's many benefits. But also, like,
from chatting with the HeatBit team, I think it'd be fair to say this is like,
they're putting heating systems, like, in your your baby's nursery. Like, this shit has to be dialed in, you know? Yes. And and what better way to
really solve for edge case safety concerns than open it up for all of the world to probe into and audit and see. So that's another huge value add from open source.
It really is. It really is. You're gonna get a lot more eyes on it. And at the end of day that's just gonna sell more of your product. Mhmm.
Cool dudes. Well, let's let's finish it up here and we'll
see you back next week.
Sounds good. Thanks a lot.
See you. See you.